bonsoir et bienvenue pour une nouvelle
édition du Journal de la rédaction de
téléfils 78 dans l'actualité de ce jeudi
9 octobre 2014 la journée mondiale du
handicap à cette occasion nous verrons
le fonctionnement des maisons
départementales des personnes
handicapées avec le directeur adjoint de
l'antenne des Yvelines Philippe Quentin
comment fonctionne ce service public qui
s'adresse aux quelques 12 millions de
Français porteurs d'un handicap le
département des Yvelines premier
département équestre en termes de
licencier ce qui n'empêche pas le
Conseil Général de se séparer du rat des
brevières les explications à suivre tout
à l'heure et puis les dialogues au
jardin permettent depuis 3 ans de
promouvoir l'excellence du métier de
paysagiste le temps d'un week-end
d'octobre les entreprises labellisées
exposent leur savoir-faire nous irons
voir le travail de l'une d'entre elles à
magny-les-moi
Saint-Cyr-l'École hier soir les élus du
conseil municipal devaient être une
nouvelle fois délibérée sur le montant
des indemnités qui leur sont versées le
précédent vote du 22 avril en effet pas
passé le contrôle de l'égalité de la
préfecture l'enveloppe globale avoisinée
les 16000 euros pour un maximum légal de
12000 euros et la répartition était
aussi erronée l'opposition socialiste
qui évoque une incompétence de la ville
le mer UMP évoque une erreur de lecture
des textes par le service des ressources
humaines
des images à présent de manileamo où se
déroulaient aujourd'hui la Journée de
défense et de citoyenneté pour les
jeunes de 17 à 18 ans une journée
obligatoire sur convocation du ministère
de la Défense au programme présentation
des différents corps armées mais aussi
des pots de gerbes de silence un
certificat indispensable pour leur
avenir a aussi été délivré à chacun
d'entre eux
les jeunes doivent se faire recenser
normalement entre 16 ans et 3 mois
serpent ils le font pour certains
d'entre eux un peu plus tard et pour
passer un diplôme d'état pour passer le
permis de conduire pour être ouvrir dans
les armées éventuellement ils doivent
avoir leur certificat de participation à
la JDC aujourd'hui ce qui leur a été
présenté ce sont différents modules sur
la défense donc les enjeux du monde
d'aujourd'hui pourquoi une défense et
quel rôle chaque citoyen peut jouer dans
ce cadre pour moi oui c'est important et
c'est même important pas que pour le
militaire mais pour enfin pour moi
personnellement c'est important pour
tout le monde en fait même si c'est pas
dans mon projet dans mon intérêt
principal mais j'ai pensé peut-être
faire une petite carrière militaire ou
peut-être devenir militaire réserviste
le seul Haras National d'Île-de-France
est donc en vente une décision du
conseil général qui peut surprendre
lorsque l'on sait que les Yvelines
compte le plus grand nombre de licenciés
d'équitation en France le reportage de
Yolaine Torres
le haras national des Bréviaires est à
vendre le Conseil général des Yvelines
propriétaires de ce terrain de plus de
40 hectares ne souhaite plus le
conserver pour le président du comité
régional d'équitation d'Île-de-France
c'est la stupéfaction bah la surprise
elle est totale parce que il est pas
question pour nous d'ailleurs de quitter
On va faire en sorte de convaincre
Pierre Bédier que c'est ce serait une
erreur la raison évoquée par Pierre
Bédier président du conseil général des
contraintes budgétaires trop importantes
et des priorités qui sont ailleurs une
décision ferme qui remet en question la
création d'un parqueteste national un
projet pour lesquels les élus du
département avaient voté une subvention
de 400 000 euros il y a un an en 2006
Pierre bédiat avait même impulsé la
mission cheval avant de faire machine
arrière cette année
à contrario de la politique qui avait
été engagée à 7 ans donc on a travaillé
pour justement faire de ce site le la
maison du cheval regroupant toutes les
composantes de la filière cheval c'est à
dire l'élevage c'est-à-dire la
commercialisation etc la formation
les 15 fonctionnaires que comptent le
haras national espère voir le futur parc
équestre aboutir mais pour le moment
leur est à l'incertitude on est dans
l'attente voilà on a envie que qu'on ait
une position claire on a envie de voir
parce que pour continuer et pour avancer
et faire des actions dans le futur il
faut qu'on sache où on va et là on
aimerait avoir une position claire et
savoir voilà qu'est-ce qu'on va devenir
et est-ce qu'on va faire plus tard le
terrain aurait été estimé à plus de 2
millions d'euros parmi les éventuels
repreneurs le président du comité
régional j'ai eu une proposition mais là
je suis dans une phase de négociation je
pense aboutir de façon raisonnable voilà
le plus vite possible
le Conseil général des Yvelines de son
côté n'a pas donné suite à nos demandes
d'interview le département des Yvelines
reste le plus cavalier de France avec
159 centres équestres et 20 000
licenciés
nous passons à l'entretien de ce journal
je reçois aujourd'hui Philippe Quentin
bonsoir directeur adjoint de la Maison
départementale des personnes handicapées
dans les Yvelines vous êtes installé sur
Versailles aujourd'hui journée mondiale
du handicap qui précède elle la Journée
internationale des personnes handicapées
du 3 décembre de date dans l'année pour
sensibiliser pour informer quelques
chiffres clés pour débuter 12 millions
de Français porteurs dans handicap 5
millions qui se déclarent en situation
de handicap il existe pour les
accueillir sans maisons départementales
comme la vôtre quelle est votre rôle
plus précisément le rôle des MDPH donc
si vous me permettez une toute petite
mise en perspective historique
20e siècle logique de réparation mutilé
du travail mutualité guerre
milieu du 20e siècle logique de
réadaptation
centrée très médicalement centré autour
des phénomènes tuberculose poliomyélite
et fin du XXe siècle évolution sociale
sociétale forte logique de compensation
2005 la loi du 11 février 2005 portée
par le Président de la République de
l'époque Monsieur Chirac avec une réelle
volonté de réformer la politique du
handicap
2005 alors pour l'égalité des droits et
des chances de la participation et de la
citoyenneté
marqué par deux piliers très forts la
compensation et l'accessibilité
pour ce faire une mise en oeuvre
départementale au plus près de la
population sans Maison départementale et
pour rectifier un tout petit peu votre
propos une particularité dans les
Yvelines d'une volonté d'accentuer
encore plus fort cette logique de
proximité la MDPH c'est 9 guichets de
proximité une maison départementale il y
a plusieurs guichets
avec les mêmes obligations pour chacun
de ces sites qui sont confiés à des
opérateurs privés au public des
associations ou des états de soins alors
voilà pour la mise en perspective le
petit rappel historique qui est
important pour bien comprendre votre
fonctionnement mais je reviens à ma
question le rôle au quotidien ça
consiste en quoi c'est MDPH
je reviens sur la logique de
compensation qui appartient qui est une
des missions forte de la MDPH
c'est-à-dire que la personne en
situation de handicap et la terminologie
n'est pas neutre je ne vous dis pas
personne handicapée c'est à dire
permettre
d'accéder à tout et à tous que ce soit
en termes d'éducation que ce soit en
termes de culture que ce soit en termes
de travail que ce soit en termes de
loisirs
pour se faire plusieurs dispositifs qui
sont à la charge de la MDPH pour une
partie ce qui était confiée
antérieurement à ceux qui s'en
souviennent ce qui était la CDES ou la
COTOREP qui était dans une logique de
prestation
et là on est vraiment dans une logique
de compensation ou on considère les
personnes en situation de handicap comme
des citoyens qui doivent pouvoir
participer à la vie sociale dans toutes
ces dimensions ça veut dire aujourd'hui
près de 160 personnes qui sont au
service de cette population et qui
exerce pleinement la mission de service
public qui est la nôtre mission de
service public ça veut dire permettre
aux personnes d'accéder aussi bien à un
établissement scolaire qu'à des
prestations ou un établissement en
fonction de leurs difficultés 2005 vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure c'est la
loi qui met en place qui évoque les
grands principes mais qui met aussi en
place vos différentes structures après
presque une dizaine d'années de
fonctionnement aujourd'hui elles sont
opérationnelles ces maisons
départementales elles fonctionnent bien
il y a encore des avancées à obtenir
dans le rapport annuel pour 2013 vous
déplorez aussi peut-être un poids pas
totalement suffisant en tout cas c'est
en route mais il y a encore des choses à
faire
notre logique de travail c'est pas une
logique de plainte on est confronté à
des situations et des personnes qui sont
en désarroi en difficulté
on fait avec ce qu'on a est-ce que avec
ce que vous avez vous arrivez à répondre
à tout ce qu'on vous demande aussi si ça
la question c'est le but c'est une
obligation de résultats permanente
ça nécessite des évolutions des
adaptations
l'évolution de la MDPH depuis 2006 date
de sa création et constante et elle
n'est pas
envisageable et réalisable sans un appui
fort de notre collectivité du conseil
général qui participent à hauteur de 40%
des moyens humains qui sont mis en œuvre
par la MDPH
alors maintenant sur la technique et les
moyens dont on dispose et comment on
dispose je vous parlais de compensation
compensation ça veut dire qu'il faut
évaluer les besoins des personnes au
plus près de leur réalité ça veut dire
que dans notre 9 points d'entrée confié
à des associations ou un établissement
de soins nous avons des équipes
pluridisciplinaires qui procèdent à
l'accueil à l'information et à
l'évaluation des besoins des personnes
ça c'est pour votre mode de
fonctionnement on l'a bien compris mais
j'en reviens tout de même à ma question
parce que je voudrais quand même savoir
si vous êtes satisfait des résultats que
vous obtenez est-ce que vous manquez
encore de moyens c'est l'Association des
Paralysés de France et encore assez peu
de temps c'est au mois de septembre qui
s'inquiétait du manque de moyens des
demandes constants constante évolution
vous l'avez rappelé c'est 60 000 cas en
2013 60 000 décisions juste en ce qui
vous concerne pour le département des
Yvelines c'est deux fois plus qu'en 2008
est-ce que les moyens aussi ont
progressé deux fois plus 2008 date
importante un crise mondiale qui affecte
désormais tous les financeurs publics
donc la logique n'est pas de de se
plaindre mais les biens de faire bien
entendu on vous a bien entendu sur ça
j'insiste beaucoup
parce que de toute façon les personnes
auprès de qui on est en devoir
d'intervenir
donc que faire de nos atermoiements sur
la plainte sur les moyens ça ne pas
progresser et ça ne fait pas avancer le
traitement des situations on a des
objectifs qui nous sont fixés à la fin
par la loi et par les financeurs à
partir de là il faut remplir ces
objectifs et sans donner les moyens PF
évoque des dysfonctionnements qui
seraient nos nombreux en raison des
manques de moyens c'est une réalité les
associations sont habilitées à exprimer
leur inquiétude mais pas vous c'est pour
ça que vous ne le direz pas ce soir
voilà mais vous n'en pensez pas moins
c'est ce qu'on va lire entre les lignes
je vous laisse libre de vos propos mais
c'est absolument pas ce que je laisse
sous-entendre en tout cas pour l'avenir
il y a eu un vote récemment l'Assemblée
nationale du projet de loi relatif à
l'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement vos établissements qui
pourraient être amenés à devenir des MDA
des maisons de l'autonomie qui vont
regrouper toutes les sphères de la
dépendance parce que ce serait une bonne
chose ou est-ce que ça fait partie d'une
inquiétude même si vous n'êtes pas là on
l'avait compris pour vous plaindre ne
croyez pas que je veux pas répondre à
votre question mais la particularité de
notre collectivité et toujours
d'anticiper l'avenir la MDA on y
réfléchit sérieusement conjointement
direction de l'autonomie maison
départementale des personnes handicapées
qui a l'avantage d'être placé sous la
même autorité administrative de son
directeur qui est directeur des deux
structures et à partir de là
l'idée n'est plus de d'inscrire la MDA
dans l'avenir immédiat mais de repenser
toute l'action sociale au niveau de la
collectivité et au même titre
qu'aujourd'hui les points d'entrée de la
MDPH sur le territoire sont les mêmes
s'inscrivent dans le même découpage
géographique que toute l'action sociale
du département demain si le Conseil
Général décide de revisiter la
répartition de ces espaces sur la base
des communautés d'agglo
la MDPH s'inscrira dans cette nouvelle
perspective géographique et de
répartition des compétences
la MDA c'est un enjeu fort parce que
d'une part elle va répondre à un des
objectifs initiaux de la loi de 2005 qui
était de servir tous les âges de la vie
aujourd'hui il y a des distinctions qui
s'opèrent à partir de l'âge de 60 ans
même si la loi avait prévu en son temps
que cette distinction devait disparaître
une dernière question parce qu'on est
malgré tout pris par le temps parler de
la structure en elle-même j'aimerais
juste avoir votre sentiment ou peut-être
aussi des exemples concrets est-ce que
la situation pour les personnes en
situation de handicap s'est amélioré
depuis 2005 depuis la création de vos
structures sincèrement oui oui je le
pense c'est une grande oeuvre de
solidarité nationale avec des
financements qui sont peut-être pas à la
hauteur de ce que les associations
espèrent mais c'est une vraie
reconnaissance du besoin de compensation
d'inscrire les personnes handicapées
dans un tissu social et à partir de là
oui nous sommes en capacité de répondre
aux besoins avec les moyens dont on
dispose merci d'être venu ce soir sur le
plateau parlez donc des MDPH chez Maison
départementale pour les personnes en
situation de handicap neuf fontaines à
travers tout le département même si ces
centralisé sur Versailles mais le même
accueil est réservé sur l'ensemble du
département Yves Linois c'est l'une des
spécificités dans notre département
merci à vous nous reprenons le cours de
ce journal du 9 octobre on estime entre
5 à 10% les jeunes de 16 à 25 ans qui
seraient sans formation un chiffre
difficile à apprécier malgré tout mais
un forum SOS rentré était proposé mardi
soir paris-lyline en formation jeunesse
à Versailles 55 jeunes qui ont été
accueillis le reportage de Catherine
zulator
Sofiane a 19 ans et veut entreprendre
une formation de commerce en alternance
mais peine à trouver un employeur hier à
Versailles l'opération SOS rentrée
organisée par l'association Yvelines
informations jeunesse était destinée à
des jeunes de 16 à 25 ans dans sa
situation
ça m'a franchement pas pu donc j'ai
décidé de le faire en alternance donc
j'ai réussi à trouver une école etc en
fait c'est juste l'employeur qui bloque
c'est l'employeur en fait à la fin qui
pose problème le jeune qui recherche un
employeur on va essayer de l'aider donc
là on a commencé un peu regarder avec
lui son CV ça l'aide de motivation et
puis on lui a donné rendez-vous pour
essayer de voir avec lui voilà comment
il allait
réorganiser peut-être sa recherche
d'emploi 9 partenaires étaient présents
pour apporter des solutions aux jeunes
car ici chaque profil est différent le
SOS rentré plutôt dédié à la formation
même si on a élargi au niveau de
l'emploi certains d'ores et déjà nous
disent ben voilà je suis rentré à
l'école mais ça va pas ça me plaît pas
donc au bout de presque un mois à peine
un mois ils savent déjà que ils vont
devoir changer de filière donc là on
peut réfléchir avec eux et voir un petit
peu les possibilités qui s'offrent c'est
un combat depuis quelques années on nous
parle du décrochage scolaire il y a trop
de jeunes qui restent sans solution
l'objectif combattre le décrochage en
dépollant les jeunes dans leur recherche
d'emploi de stage ou de formation pour
cette journée l'association a reçu 55
jeunes dans les Yvelines selon le CIO 5
à 10% des 16-25 ans serait dans cette
situation
un tout autre sujet à présent la saison
de la chasse a commencé dans les
Yvelines depuis un mois une activité
pratiquée par une population de
passionnés de plus en plus vieillissante
mais nous avons rencontré Kevin le bois
24 ans qui tente de rajeunir la chasse
en Île-de-France nous l'avons suivi avec
sa famille lors d'un week-end
dimanche à Jumeauville quand on est
chasseur pas de grasse matinée le
week-end car c'est à l'aube que l'on
réalise les plus belles prises à
seulement 24 ans Kevin entame sa sixième
saison de chasse aujourd'hui il traque
le petit gibier
dans le champ de maïs des perdreaux que
son chien pousse vers la sortie
Vénus fil chercher le volatile abattu
chien et chasseur forment de véritable
duo c'est le travail du chien
si on n'a pas le chien voir les arrêts
voir la réaction le chien on connaît par
cœur dès qu'il sent bon allez
mais le flair de Vénus ne suffira pas ce
matin impossible de retrouver le
perdreau la semaine Kevin et jardinier
attrapent la chasse et son passe-temps
favori sa passion si son oncle qui lui a
tout appris s'il a décidé de prendre la
tête de l'association des jeunes
chasseurs c'est pour faire perdurer
cette tradition en Île-de-France seul
10% des chasseurs ont moins de 30 ans
les jeunes chasseurs ont un peu l'avenir
de la chasse la chasse c'est quand même
une belle tradition les rois chassés ça
fait des lustres des lustres donc
c'est comme tout c'est un patrimoine à
préserver et
si on le préserve pas nous jeune
chasseurs dans quelques temps la chasse
sera comment dire on embauchera des
fonctionnaires pour aller chasser quoi
quand il y aura trop de sangliers trop
de sel car pour Kevin la chasse est
aussi un moyen de réguler les
populations et donc de préserver la
biodiversité le nombre d'animaux abattus
est d'ailleurs très réglementé François
a été plus chanceux il prélever son
lièvre comme on dit dans le jargon son
deuxième de la saison le Kota est
atteint pour cette année il n'a plus le
droit d'en tuer ici aujourd'hui c'est
une sortie en famille Thomas le
beau-frère de Kevin chasse depuis 13 ans
une passion qu'il dit innée son fusible
lui a été légué par son grand-père ce
qui me plaît dans la chasse c'est la
convivialité c'est de voir des animaux
bon des animaux lâchés comme on peut
voir dans certains reportages et dans
certaines chasses ça ne me plaît pas du
tout je préfère voir beaucoup moins de
gibier voir une perdrix comme on peut
avoir eu l'exemple là ce matin ça c'est
du gibier sauvage tous deux connaissent
toutes les espèces des environs la faune
et la flore non plus de secret pour eux
ils sont là là
attention il y en a une là
qui ne repartira finalement pas
bredouille donc une petite compagnie de
perdreau j'ai réussi en décrocher tu as
vu
bon ben on a couru un peu mais ça va lui
la peine
une fois la saison finie il passeront
leur week-end à préparer les terrains
les nettoyer pour favoriser la
reproduction du gibier c'est aussi ça
être chasseur
dialogo jardin c'est le nom de
l'opération mené depuis trois ans à
travers la France pour promouvoir le
métier de paysagiste l'entreprise Les
Jardins de la vallée qui est implanté à
Magny-les-Hameaux à participer à ce
rendez-vous annuel du week-end dernier
avec des porte-ouvertes interactives
vous allez le voir
bienvenue dans le jardin de la
relaxation un jardin conçu autour d'un
bassin d'eau par des étudiants du chef
du Tremblay-sur-Mauldre ici tout n'est
qu'apaisement de l'esprit on a voulu
mettre en œuvre
tout ça pour que ça soit un espace
détente tout le monde que toutes les
personnes qui viennent puissent partir
partir du projet en étant relaxé tendu
et déstresser quoi quand on arrive on
entend le le bruit de l'eau
sorte de cascade on appelle ça une
lambdo après il y a le dallage c'est
l'élément aussi important parce que
c'est des grosses dalles et c'est ce qui
marque aussi ce qui fait ressortir le
bassin les dalles grises à faire sortir
le bassin qui est noir
un peu plus loin c'est un autre jardin
conçu par l'école tecoma de
Jouy-en-Josas le travail est la plus
technique des dalles de 200 kg posées
sur des chevrons cela demande un certain
savoir-faire j'adore être dehors et
la création aussi
pouvoir imaginer
des chantiers des jardins
moi ce que je préfère ça maçonnerie
aussi c'est beaucoup plus apprécision et
de l'attention donc c'est ça que je
préfère ils ont tout fait de A à Z alors
le choix des matériaux a été fait en
collaboration avec les élèves dans un
premier temps
ils ont choisi l'emplacement ils sont
venus faire une visite de repérage
après ils ont ils nous ont proposé ils
nous ont proposé la conception de leur
jardin qui a été supervisé par notre
bureau d'études quand même c'est jardin
éphémères étaient notés à la fois par
des professionnels et par le public le
but montrer les tendances des jardins de
demain un jardin à la fois lieu d'éveil
de sérénité mais aussi de découverte et
d'audace ce n'est d'ailleurs pas un
hasard si le jardin récompensé s'appelle
l'exploration des sens il a été conçu
par les élèves de l'école Saint-Nicolas
d'Igny en tout cas étudiants ont
participé à ce concours
musique pour terminer ce jour ce journal
c'est au travers de quatre résidences
artistiques dont l'une à la batterie à
Guyancourt que Louis karatini profine
pour film son projet intitulé pour la
bonne cause spectacle original de
chansons françaises sera présentée au
public à l'aube 2015 le reportage il y a
Debussy et les images de William L
les yeux sont toujours blancs salle des
nuages envahissent nos yeux
le gris c'est un miroir
qui ternit un reflet des formes
si à l'ombre du soir le ciel le vivant
noir c'est pour mieux voir le firmament
moi là-bas j'étais plutôt comédien de
formation et musiciens aussi j'avais un
peu les deux et puis un jour je lui dis
tiens faire la deuxième en même temps
faire de la chanson ça m'intéresse quand
j'ai commencé à écrire ça c'était il y a
environ 3-4 ans j'ai commencé vraiment à
faire un projet solo et de fil en
aiguille j'ai rencontré une production
qu'on peut faire une sorte de compagnie
musicale Lulu prod qui a un
fonctionnement intéressant en fait c'est
qu'il travaille comme des compagnies de
théâtre c'est à dire qu'on a des
résidences on a un mois de résidence
dans un endroit ici donc cette semaine
ici une semaine de résidence à
Guyancourt avec justement des temps
dédié donc ici le son et donc avec Lulu
prod c'est à partir de là on s'est dit
tiens on va créer vraiment un spectacle
complet total c'est pas juste un tour de
chant on essaie de casser les espaces
aussi pour faire vraiment utiliser des
outils théâtre utiliser des outils de
musique aussi évidemment mais pour
sortir d'un concert de chansons
françaises traditionnelles mais avoir
des espaces différents avoir puis
raconter des histoires
c'est plus sur le ciel et s'il pleut
aussi gras là je vais plus sereine
j'essaie toujours de glisser une petite
part de philosophie dans les dans les
chansons d'avoir sans faire non plus de
la morale c'est pas bien ou mal c'est
juste subjectif c'est mon point de vue
sur un petit quelque chose c'est
toujours
mettre du fond et trouver des formes
innovantes
bien que ça coûte aux habitants
d'une macada
car ce sont les seuls qui t'écoutent
petite madame
j'essaie d'avoir une exigence musicale
textuelle partout et en même temps j'ai
toujours un lien très fort avec le
public sur scène parce que je suis
comédien et l'interaction que le public
c'est la première chose donc j'essaie
d'avoir quelque chose de très exigeant
derrière musicalement textuellement mais
en même temps d'avoir de donner ça d'une
manière extrêmement simple c'est ça et
puis de la générosité je pense qu'il
faut juste tout donner et travailler
comme des malades voilà pour la bonne
cause c'est simple c'est c'est tout ce
qu'on donne
gratuitement c'est là où je parle de
générosité c'est à dire
peu importe ce qu'on reçoit il faut le
donner et le pour la bonne cause c'est
on se bat un peu pour parce qu'on se bat
pour des idéaux artistiques politiques
et on le fait toujours pour la bonne
cause et dans ce titre il y a à la fois
à la fois l'engagement et en même temps
l'humour dessus de se dire en même temps
on sait très bien qu'on fait ça pour la
bonne cause parce que est-ce que nos
engagements sont vraiment aboutis et
seront vraiment réalisés on sait jamais
en fait la vie parfois nous impose des
choses mais c'est
c'est voilà juste une grande générosité
je sais pas il y a des gens qui me
disent la chanson française jazzy j'ai
des gens qui font ah tu fais de la
chanson française rock et d'autres qui
ont ah j'aime bien aimé latin et puis il
y a des gens qui font non c'est pas de
la chanson française c'est de la poésie
en mouvement
c'est de la com c'est du marketing après
je suis d'accord c'est vrai il faut
avoir une étiquette c'est bien je vais
essayer de m'en coller une maintenant je
vais dire de la chanson rocambolesque
en gardant ma personne je récupère mon
dieu
tout ce que je vends je n'ai jamais
perdu
en gardant ma personne je récupère mon
dieu
le journal qui revient demain vendredi
au même horaires excellente soirée sur
notre antenne